well the tampa bay buccaneers execute
the first trade of the night moving up
one spot from number 14 to number 13 to
get iowa tackle tristan worse exactly
what they need to help provide
protection for tom brady the new
quarterback who will be 43 years old in
august and maybe holding the ball a
little bit longer in brucerian's offense
they need to protect it worse can play
either side and worse can do a lot of
things weight lifter disc is shot put a
good athlete who
helps make that offensive line better
how much better we'll see we know that
tom brady gets rid of the ball very
quickly so it's not like you hold the
block for six or seven seconds and you
know what it wouldn't shock me if they
ultimately flipped them to the inside
because my biggest concern for tom brady
is pressure up the middle not on the
outside when he comes around the edges
he knows how to step up step away slide
away and make the throw he has the
biggest trouble we've seen this
historically when the pressure is in his
face so would it would it stun me if
worth plays guard it wouldn't stun me
the guy could do whatever they wanted to
do and he has shown that he can do
anything he wants to do and what the
buccaneers wanted to do was move up they
got their guy and now they continue to
put pieces around their newest additions
tom brady and rob gronkowski
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports